Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P Yesterday,
I played a clip of Jim
Speaker 2: Breuer for you.
Speaker 1: The Egg Man, who has been a loyal
listener for 14 years, called in and said,
I've never fast forwarded anything
you've done until you said the name
Jim Breuer. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Dave, I listened to your
show regularly for, I don't know, 14 years, a
really long time, dude. I've never fast forwarded
an interview the most boring interviews
I listen to. I've learned so much about
being an old man like Ari Degré. I'm going to live
to be a thousand. I've learned so much. No matter
how boring it is. But when you play Jim Breuer, I
fast forward 30 seconds. Fast forward 30 seconds.
As soon as you said that guy's name, fellow yes.
Speaker 2: Not a completely unique reaction.
Speaker 1: I got a number of emails from
people saying I couldn't listen to that.
Speaker 2: It was to cringe and listen.
Speaker 1: I apologized after playing the clip,
after all. We've got a great bonus show for
you today. Sign up at Join Packman dot com.
Speaker 2: You'll get instant
Speaker 1: access to the
bonus show. And remember to get on my
Speaker 2: newsletter, my mailing list at David
Speaker 1: Pakman dot com January 1st will be
doing a borderline illegal membership discount
special, trying to kick off twenty two off
strongly, very strongly. In fact, we're
Speaker 2: looking at it. Sign up for
Speaker 1: my mailing list at David
Pakman Gqom. We'll see you on the bones
Unidentified: show and the.